cette vidéo a été prise le 8 juin 2021
et posent beaucoup de questions
concernant la sécurité du président de
la république alors suite à cet acte de
violence on peut se demander si emmanuel
macron se met en danger
on y répond dans facture pour mieux
comprendre ce qui s'est passé pendant ce
bain de foule à tain l'hermitage on doit
d'abord se demander comment fonctionne
la sécurité du président de la
république sous la vème république tous
les présidents était placée sous une
protection personnelle est immédiate
depuis 1983 elle s'appelle le gspr
acronyme de groupe de sécurité de la
présidence de la république qui est
composée de gendarmes et de policiers
ce groupe assure sur le territoire
français et à l'étranger la protection
personnelle immédiate du président de la
république et la sécurité de ses
déplacements
ce sont les hommes qu'on peut voir sur
ces images qui entourent
systématiquement le président de la
république dans tous ses déplacements
maintenant qu'on en sait un peu plus sur
ce groupe de sécurité qui accompagnent
emmanuel macron dans ses déplacements va
pouvoir se pencher sur ce qu'il s'est
passé le 8 juin dans la drôme lorsqu'on
a vu à temps à mes amis tôt c'est un
président qui échappait aux services de
sécurité pour aller serrer des mains
d'un groupe de personnes qui étaient
présents sur place et kiss bang se fait
gifler par l'une des personnes présentes
de personnes avaient été fouillées donc
on a cherché si vous avez des armes des
canettes de bière de choses comme ça
qu'il aurait pu lancer utilisés comme
projectiles ou avec lesquelles il aurait
pu frapper le chef de l'état ne peut pas
priver quelqu'un par définition de ses
mains pour cet épisode de factures nous
avons pu entrer en contact avec une
source policière
connaisseur de la sécurité des
personnalités publiques est toujours en
activité qui a pu décrypter cette scène
pour nous pour préserver son anonymat
nous avons retranscrit les informations
qui nous a confié pour chaque
déplacement il ne faut pas oublier qu'il
y ait une préparation en amont qui
permet d'organiser la protection passive
dans le cas du déplacement du président
de la république on comprend rapidement
que les agents ont été pris par surprise
par l' approche rapide emmanuel macron
vers la foule puisque en france la
coutume veut que le président soit libre
de ses déplacements
quitte à mettre de côté sa sécurité donc
les officiers de sécurité prenne une
distance avec la personnalité qui n'est
pas inscrite dans le protocole initial
il y à un aménagement qui est fait pour
l'image et donc on a une régression de
la sécurité et on a donc un temps de
latence qu'on essaie de diminuer au
maximum et dans le cas de ce déplacement
le temps de latence pour l'adaptation
était trop long donc ça a laissé place
cet événement de se produire pour mieux
comprendre à quoi correspond ce temps de
latence
on le voit très clairement ici en 2009
lorsqu'un individu a enjambé une
barrière pendant une messe de minuit
pour s'attaquer à benoît 16 on voit que
les agents de sécurité ont réagi mais
pas assez vite pour empêcher la chute du
pape mais ce qu'on peut retenir de cet
événement c'est que la protection d'un
président ça se résume à faire des
concessions sur la sécurité pour
augmenter le confort c'est un euphémisme
pour laisser croire à une société où
tout va bien donner une image lisse
rappelez vous de cette affaire datant de
2018 nous passerons les détails sur
cette affaire mais ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est qu'alexandre benalla était chargée
de la sécurité des manuels macro et ils
le suivaient partout dans tous ses
déplacements
suite à cette affaire le sénat avait
établi dans son rapport d' enquête
qu'alexandre benalla s'était attribué un
rôle actif dans l'organisation et la
gestion de la sécurité de la présidence
de la république sans que sa hiérarchie
et fait obstacle
mais les affaires entre emmanuel macron
et sa sécurité ne s'arrête pas là en
2017 dans le documentaire
emmanuel macron les coulisses d'une
victoire on surprend le futur président
de la république dire je ne peux pas
paraître planqué si vous écoutez les
mecs de la sécurité vous finissez comme
françois hollande
peut-être que vous êtes en sécurité mais
vous êtes mort emmanuel macron cherche
donc à être en opposition avec son
prédécesseur sur les questions de
sécurité
pourtant d'après un rapport de la cour
des comptes datant de 2019
on apprend qu'il y a eu une augmentation
des dépenses en masse salariale d'un
virgule 2 millions d'euros entre 2017 et
2018 pour la sécurité globale du
président qui englobe les deux entités
le gspr et la garde républicaine donc
emmanuel macron ne souhaite pas paraître
planqué mais on constate une
augmentation des effectifs du gspr
biassette
cette volonté de jouer au héros c'est à
dire qu'au fond pour emmanuel macron
s'il reconnaît qu'il a besoin d'un
service de sécurité s'ils se protègent
du coc vide ou des agressions
extérieures
il est moins aéro et s'ils ne se
protéger par est en fait c'est hors
sujet parce que c'est pas lui qui est
important c'est l'état
est ce qu'on doit protéger c'est pas lui
c'est un président il y en aura d'autres
c'est l'état qu'on doit protéger puisque
l'état il est toujours là la grande
leçon de cette séquence a été diffusée
partout dans le monde dans tous les
médias internationaux y compris les plus
gros médias américains on sait que notre
président de la république est l'une des
rames
c'est l'image pourra voir l'extérieur
donc on ne protégera pas efficace pour
nos présidents c'est l'image ou en verre
à titre de comparaison les états unis
sont intransigeants en termes de
sécurité de leur président suite à
l'assassinât du président mckinley en
1901 il ne lésine pas sur la sécurité du
chef de l'état puisque contrairement à
la france
outre atlantique ce n'est pas le
président qui mène la danse mais les
agents donc il est parfaitement anormal
qu'on n'est pas un système comme aux
états unis ou quand le président est élu
immédiatement le service de sécurité
arrive et lui impose des normes de
sécurité il n'a pas le choix le
président aujourd'hui il faut compter en
à une société mature avec un service de
sécurité qui s'imposent au président et
qu'on ne laisse pas au président le
choix ou non de se protéger
[Musique]
l'eau